there is no meaning to life without a
challenge and the symptom of greatness
is to accept that challenge
in a very sportive spirit so many things
keep happening in life let the small
things pass by and focus on what's
important I want to say one thing just
one and probably this will change the
direction of your life
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world now I started the
Metta me series to try to hang your own
people who've done a lot more than us
and by spending a little more time with
them hopefully their mindsets their
beliefs their attitudes their way of
seeing the world seep in to us to help
us become the best version of ourselves
so today we're gonna learn from one of
the best Gower Gopal das and how to stay
motivated mentor me goer
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one grow through challenges
challenges are such an integral part of
growth in our life for example a teacher
will always pose higher and higher
challenges to the students anyone who's
interested in physical fitness the
fitness coach the trainer will pose
higher and higher challenges even in
relationships for that matter life poses
so many challenges there is no meaning
to life without a challenge and the
symptom of greatness is to accept that
challenge in a very sportive spirit and
learn how to go deeper in whatever we
are doing rule number two is change your
perspective recently a guy came up to me
and was grumbling for all the problems
the troubles the difficulties that he
was going through he had just recently
lost his job for no reason his
relationships were on a deep mess nobody
was trying to understand him
everything was going wrong and he had
done nothing wrong and all through the
conversation he kept asking me why is
this happening to me
I'm sure a lot of you can relate to the
situation that this guy was going
through I told him look man do what you
can do to sort it out
if it's your fault corrected if it's
someone else's fault and that person was
within your access discuss with them
communicate to them
very often however what we go through is
neither our fault
all of someone else for example a
serious disease that we go to we didn't
do anything wrong to get
have a skynyrd how do we do
here's what we did
a little boy once came running to his
mother and asked her what are you doing
wrong she replied I'm making a beautiful
embroidered design on this nice plot the
little boy looked up to the clot
securely and in the wooden ring the home
and complained a design all I can see is
just some colored threads the yellow
blue red black pink all tangled up all
messed up into each other all
complication and you call it a design
the mother
the little boy put him on her lap
and said to him now look at it my son
and the boy saw a beautiful design
an incredible pattern a systematic plan
an allele a one wing on this plot the
mother said to the boy
when you look at the cloth from your
side all you see is a mess when you look
at the cloth from my side all you see is
a beautiful design a pattern
ladies and gentlemen when we go to the
helpless overwhelming challenges in our
life for no fault of ours or no fault of
anybody else and we cannot do anything
to sort it out if we see and look at it
from our point of view
all we see is a mess all we see is
situations and events tangled up and
jumbled up to create that mess but when
we look at the same situation from
life's point of view from God's point of
view we see a beautiful design a pattern
a plan evolving in
rule number three is don't give in I
will do something in the game of life
you're playing a cricket match against
an entity called the mind no one on
planet earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can bat
against the googly that the mind pulls
at you how many of you have experienced
that the mild bolds Pugliese good when
it comes to exercising and jogging how
many of you know that the mind bulls
boogies much ah so ja how many of you
have trouble in studying students and
you come here you hear all of these
things don't get distracted by whatsapp
don't get distracted by internet
pornography don't get distracted by
Twitter don't get distracted by Facebook
study don't get distracted by birds to
do bird-watching study all these
distractions is the racket which updates
later gulosa do look up to be filter so
on father was telling his son take the
Xterra class me Lucy and a Lucy baby
they first by you or two now like hey
Logan Oh Bella dig they came hey look
[Applause]
I'll tell you something my god why
because the mind doesn't want you to win
the game of life how many of you wanted
to wake up early in the morning
residents only one did I asked wanted to
wake up early in the morning and how
many of you have done something called
as setting an alarm clock and then after
setting the alarm clock that's an alarm
well you want it or not it rings and
when it rings the mind puts its first
GUI what does the mind do by putting the
googley makes you clean bold when you do
the first sluice
you are out
you are out if you snooze you are out I
want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the Allah what happens you decide
to give in to the mind spot
and this is how your morning begins by
giving into the mind
sabira Kishore wa to PA his Wohlers a
clean bowled oj oj cam and dipping it
into the English robot a by giving him
and there's no problem giving in
slipping five minutes extra is no
problem the problem is you develop the
attitude of giving him you tell yourself
that what I decided last night is not as
important what is important is what the
mind sets because we listen I'll tell
you something my humble advice because
it's not just about getting up in the
morning it's about every aspect of life
whether it's your work if you're working
whether it's your study it will study
whatever we do
the problem is it's not about one thing
Saverio viana it reflects in every area
of life is limited oh avatar was an
animal uma hipness an iota jarvis column
la garlic and char pisco poor don't
allow that snooze rule number four focus
when one looks at the cream standing on
one leg completely focused into the
waters the crane with one pointed
attention is looking at the waters as
the fishes are swimming inside the water
the crane will allow the tiny the small
fish to swim around and not be satisfied
with them it'll allow the fishes the
small fishes to go around and swim
around the crane will focus and wait for
the big fish to come if the Korean
settles with the small fish it lose the
big fish and as a crane wants the big
fish it has to allow the small fish to
pass by and go around
similarly in life when you want to focus
on what is important we should allow the
small things to pass why we shouldn't be
distracted by the little things
sometimes they'll be interpersonal
issues and conflicts sometimes there'll
be some health crises sometimes there
might be a financial crisis so many
things keep happening in life let the
small things pass by and focus on what's
important and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
utilize the power up together Ness again
I was in San Francisco
and one of my friends was driving me
over possibly one of the most beautiful
bridges in the world but most certainly
one of the most photographed bridge in
the world the Golden Gate Bridge I was
wanting to know more about the bridge so
at the end of the bridge my friend
stopped the car and took me to a spot
where they had a cross section of one of
the suspension cables and also other
information about the bridge written
there the Golden Gate Bridge spans 4200
feet the suspension cable from where the
bridge is suspended is seven thousand
six hundred and fifty feet long and
three feet or 36 inches in diameter when
I looked at the cross section of the
cable what was astounding to me was that
this cable wasn't made in a single mode
this cable was made of twenty seven
thousand five hundred and seventy two
pin wires all obviously seven thousand
six hundred and fifty feet long
the Golden Gate Bridge was reiterating a
very powerful principle to me the power
of togetherness
not only does working together satisfy a
heart but working together can help us
contribute something incredibly
spectacular to serve the people of this
world just as this 27,000 572 tiny wires
together contributed a bridge for people
to cross over a body of water moreover
these wires thin wires could never be
able to bear the huge weight of the
bridge and the weight of the cars
commuting on the bridge by themselves
but together they were able to handle so
much pressure they were able to handle
so much weight they were able to handle
the adversities of weather the frigid
winters the hot summers the cyclones the
tornadoes the Hurricanes I was astounded
by this power of togetherness
now I've got a very special bonus clip
on how to find your dried that I think
you're really going to enjoy but before
that my question of the day for you is I
want to know what is the biggest
challenge that you have had to grow
through I would love to hear from you
please leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
simple small purse and Sanskrit they're
the worse which is muqam Marathi watch a
low even a dumb man can speak on whom
long riot they give him even a lame man
can cross the mountain lattaker pitamaha
one day she will be in a pair of them
it's by the grace of sri guru and God
that one can do what we are doing and
therefore if you ask me what is my
motivation to keep going I don't even
think I am inspiring millions or crores
as you said people are watching and
people are hearing it's not my knowledge
it's the knowledge coming from God it's
the knowledge coming from my guru and so
many other monks in the monastery from
whom I learn I simply act as a
microphone a microphone simply amplifies
the voice of the speaker so if there's
something that's motivating people it's
not me it's the knowledge and the power
of that grace that is behind me which is
unseen to your eyes you can't see that
but that's the life that I live when you
don't see me on screens I am in a
monastery in a small little room every
morning practicing my spiritual sadhana
every morning connecting to God through
the chanting of the holy names every
morning I sit and listen to the other
monks I'm not only speaking I sit there
I hear others you know I learn from them
and I'm tremendously inspired by the
picture that I showed you Chino
Prabhupada his life and tremendously
inspired by his example and of course my
guru rather not my eyes
tirelessly keeps on going and serving if
there's anything that motivates me
it's my chanting it's my hearing it's a
company of my guru and other like-minded
monks that's what keeps me going
raise your standard apple at the core
its core value is that that people with
passion can change the world
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details